[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name is Baris Ozaydini.
I'm the founder
and CEO of FitWell.
FitWell is a mobile
coaching app that
simplifies being fit
and healthy by offering
the experience of a personal
trainer, a nutritionist,
and a life coach, all together.
So the goal of the
Lean process was
to create a minimum viable
product and a prototype.
By minimum viable product,
I mean the core product
with the key features that
we can quickly roll out,
without the fancy stuff
or bells and whistles,
that will give us core input
from the early adopters,
so that we can start
learning from it.
First step of the process
was to get a good team
from multidisciplinary areas.
First, a designer, a UX
expert, a Lean advisor,
a project manager, and a
product manager all together.
The reason of getting a
multidisciplinary team
is simply because you need
different kinds of opinions
into this process
and you need to be
able to create a result
from this process,
so you need different
expertise areas in your team.
We started with the core idea
of creating a mobile coach.
And as a team, we discussed
each and every aspect
of creating a product, starting
from the core paying points,
the customer, the marketplace,
and the key features that
would make the product.
After a while, we came up
with several hypotheses
about the marketplace, the
product, the need out there,
and our customers.
One of the most important
things about the Lean process
is to know about your customer.
You have to really define
who you are working for,
who you are trying to
solve the problem for.
We call this the core persona.
So together with the team,
we defined our core persona.
Actually, everybody
had different ideas
of the core persona,
so we voted which
one would make the most sense.
After we came up with
the core persona idea,
we said, let's test our
ideas and test our hypothesis
in the marketplace.
So we booked some
interviews with real people
and went to the field.
Then we went back
to the war room.
People had a lot of
experience with real people
and a lot of insights, so we
put them all in the funnel.
We started live
discussion again,
and we came out with the
MVP, with real features
that would appeal to people.
After defining the MVP
and the key features,
we created a prototype.
It was a non-functional,
but a visual one.
We used the prototype in
real business scenarios
as well, securing an investment
as well as securing a business
deal with a important partner.
After having the
MVP and prototype,
developing the product was
pretty straightforward.
In six months, we released
the product in Turkey
as a beta market.
It took us five days to
become the number one health
and fitness app in Turkey.
And we're using the
Lean Methodology still,
and we now have 400,000
members in six months.
[MUSIC PLAYING]